all right Steven is in Lexington hi
Steven how are you hey thanks for taking
my call I appreciate it
sure quick yeah quick question I wanted
to get some pros and cons and we're
doing really well we've been on your
plane for about five or six years I've
saved up quite a bit of money for a down
payment on a rental property how much
and I guess twenty five thousand okay
good so I'm struggling with the you know
because I'm trying to put all my
investments and trying to max all those
out
I guess I'm struggling at trying to get
to about 120 or 125 30% down 15 year on
an investment property and just go it
really slow well maybe add three a year
or something or not three-year but one
every three years I'm just trying to get
pros cons and the cons are huge real
estate investment real estate with debt
on it as a nightmare you just added a
ton of risk and stress to your life you
change the way you deal with the tenant
you change the way you deal with
everything so just take your time pay
cash for your property how much are you
putting doing into investments otherwise
I'm maxing my Roth at work and then just
I'm dripping a little bit into just an
IRA
so what total dollars are you putting
into investments into these I'm doing
almost 15% into my IRA what total
dollars are you putting into investment
or any okay $24,000 a year in your
household income is what and it
fluctuates so say 150 to 225 okay good
and okay good and how much is in your
401ks now probably okay and how old are
you 34 and is your home paid for not yet
okay well what we teach is for you to
get your house paid for as soon as
possible and then I might slow down some
of my
retirement contributions a slight amount
below the 15% and build up cash even
faster to buy the nectar by the first
piece of real estate with cash it's the
hardest piece of real estate you buy
with cash investment real estate Steven
is the first one because after that
you've got that property cash flowing
like a bandit that's going to take care
of the next one and then you got to cash
flowing like a bandit that are going to
take you into the next one and man it
took me forever to get my first one but
I quit borrowing money and I quit
recommending people borrow money so I
want you to take the twenty five
thousand and work your baby steps that
twenty five thousand should be gone baby
step six
it should be on your home how much do
you owe on your hair I like 192 okay
let's get that finish man as soon as
possible you have plenty of time you're
going to be wealthy you're going to be a
multimillionaire
in your 50s so just chill just chill
yeah and that's that's what you get in
patients are going to screw this whole
thing up dude okay you're going to do it
and you know it doesn't sound like I'm
gonna be able to stop you but don't do
it I've done it I've watched people and
you're going to learn about rental
property things you don't want to know
if you buy it on a dad-blame debt you're
going to wish you hadn't it's that
simple and hey man thank you for the
call we appreciate you being a listener
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income a $500,000 ending
you